babes I have the biggest shows of My
Life this weekend tomorrow I am at Radio
City Music Hall in New York city that
show is sold out but you can still get
tickets to see me in New York City for
the last time in probably two years the
theater at Madison Square Garden this
Saturday September 23rd we still have
Tiki wikis available at
chrisdcomedy.com and if you can't get
into that go fly to Las Vegas because
next Saturday September 30th I'm at the
Cosmopolitan okay so if you can't make
it this Saturday to New York City and
see me come out next Saturday make it a
Vegas trip your boys your girls your
babies
christycomedy.com September 30th I am at
the Cosmopolitan in Las Vegas thank you
so much for the support I appreciate it
go get the tiki wikis guys tickets for
my special in Chicago on December 2nd
went on sale last week and they sold out
uh on the first day because of you guys
I am so grateful uh that we are going to
add another two shows but that is it I'm
not editing any more than this but this
is the huge announcement right now they
went on sale on Friday
um we are going to do Friday December
1st as well tickets are on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com uh they are
on sale you don't even need a promo code
I am not adding more shows after this
the first two sold out immediately so if
you were waiting or thinking about
getting tickets it's Friday December 1st
those are on sale at savalcano
comedy.com and I will say because I've
been being asked a lot
the contest still stands if you are
going to any of my tapings any of the
four tapings for my uh stand up comedy
special I'm going to choose one ticket
it doesn't matter where you sit and it
doesn't matter what taping you're at I'm
going to choose one person give you a
plus one I'm going to fly you to New
York put you up in an hotel and bring
you on a set of Impractical Jokers I
want to do that as a thank you to you
guys because I couldn't believe it sold
out so fast so you're still in it to win
it if you buy a ticket savocano
comedy.com right now Friday December 1st
at the Vic in Chicago if you have a
friend that lives in Chicago around that
area let them know again I'm going to
pick one person out of those tapings it
doesn't matter where you sit so grab
those right away the rest of the tour is
also still on sale with tons of dates
um as a matter of fact this coming
weekend I will be in uh
Bowling Green Kentucky uh Cincinnati
Ohio and Toledo and then we're moving on
to Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania and
Wilmington Delaware in October we have
Macon Savannah and Athens Georgia and
even more and more dates all them up
right now on sale at seattlecounty.com
the Impractical Jokers cruise is January
22nd to the 26th with Eric Andre with
Stevo and we're announcing tons of more
Comedians and bands this coming week
there's only a few cabins left for that
you can go get those at get ship faced
haha cruise.com that's get
shipfacecrews.com check out nopresh.com
noprushnetwork.com from merch and
savvalkano comedy.com for my merch I
love you guys thank you so much for your
support I really hope to see you on the
road
don't run
[Music]
away say hey babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe it's Thursday and you know
what that means
everyone
loves hey babes now scissor man
[Applause]
what do you think of the new intro uh I
like it I like it I like it for at least
a little bit I like to switch it up and
uh big fan so babe we have to pay money
for that we pay Dash money we haven't
spoken
about my birthday party at my house holy
crap we that was in my opinion you guys
gave me a surprise party Jasmine
organized the whole surprise party I
didn't know until I was pulling into my
driveway and I saw my neighbor's car in
the drive I was like okay so everyone's
there oh no it was his neighbor parked
in the driveway yes it was a 70s themed
party yeah it was in for me I hope it
was for you but I want your honest
assessment the most fun I've had in
years the most fun house party I've had
in years you got introduced to one of
our friends Chrissy the worm who you
love yeah now I need that kid in my life
for real need that kid in my life and I
I you know we did shrooms we drank we
had food it was the right concoction of
people and it was like a house party in
my opinion that like you see in the
movies kind of that's what we've talked
about that's how I described it
everything you said I completely agree
with I don't remember the last time I
was at a party that was like that just
like everybody was on the exact same
page yeah and everyone was having the
same amount of fun right like you know
House Parties don't really and like you
said it was like a house party from a
movie right it was and the video Let's
Play The I'm gonna send you the video
from my phone right now pimpy there was
a video that that I made and I barely
remember making this video somebody was
recording me and I did I was reading
from a book I walked into your first of
all everyone's outside everyone right
everyone right I walked into the house
and there was one dude there who was
overloaded on shrooms right and right
the shroom guy the guy that brought this
room right Corey Corey shrooms and you
were reading excerpts from a book out
loud yes I just sent it to you pimp let
me know when you get it and then maybe
we could we could play that because it
was there might be a little thing we had
to do with it but I don't know I don't
think no what do you think I don't know
I don't remember it so I gotta like
watch no I mean yeah yeah if you don't
if we don't like it we can two tanks I
just texted it to you did it come
through yet no so I I went there it was
a fun theme everybody like committed to
the theme right uh it was a surprise
party that's always fun right and uh it
was a beautiful night beautiful weather
we had a lot going for it but never did
I expect for it to end and turn out like
how it turned out there was a switch
flipped at some point in the night it
was one of those parties where I
normally when things like that happen
you know I get my social anxiety
whatever and I'm like I just want I want
to leave I want to go home I want to go
to bed soon I did not want that party to
end at all here's the video This Is Me
we're well into shrooms and drinking
right now
the party's outside parties outside I
picked up Ryan Holliday still this is
the key here's Chris
Sal's eating the food
[Music]
I have on a tombolo shirt that Sal
bought for me that's Sal's birthday gift
I'm wearing
and white pants from CBS
this is you're in your own world
there's Corey the wheat mushrooms guy
yeah
he ran over he ran over
yeah the entire party's outside there
who knows what Prince is doing look at
him he's trying to what is he looking
for he went to the bathroom right before
you started this kid's stealing
from my cupboard he's stealing my spices
he walked in right before he started and
walked out when you finished and he was
like what the hell is going on out here
it was in real time that felt like you
you were you're reading for a half hour
yeah yeah I I remember I I remember
thinking in the middle of that I said
I'm going to end this with this is hey
babe when I feel it's right to Dismount
I'm going to Dismount I and I had no
idea it was coming and I'm trying to
make a plate right and uh you were going
on and on but but it's funny because
when I came in you were doing that
already I think with another book yeah
there was only you and it was only you
in the Corey no I didn't think nobody
was even filming me I was just doing
that I was reading it aloud and that's
why I was like what is going on well
because because I think I just said you
know what I in my mushroom State I said
you know people back in the day what a
big thing was is you were just people
would just read books outside to be like
that like if you were going on a boat if
you're going on a book tour you know in
the 1800s you would just stand on a
corner and read your book and people be
like what is that no it's my book so I
was like let me just read this let me
read someone else's book but I don't
know why I did it you started getting
your you know you could do it put your
ass into it I did a ProMaster to it yeah
and then you blindsided me and I was we
were on I guess a lot of that I had by
the end of the night I had a full
chocolate bar oh my God and then and
then someone put an actual actual
Mushroom in my mouth yeah I think it was
the mushroom guy yeah I I as well um was
I was I was fully loaded
um and um
shut up or cry sure I um
it was truly like one of those things
where I was like wow this is like that
was for my 39th birthday for my 40th if
I make it I don't I don't I don't
actually want to do anything because I I
actually don't even want to ever have
another birthday party again because
that was I had so much fun you can't
recreate it and you wore a you had a
dsny shirt on and dsny shorts from
tombolo and it looks awesome God bless
you all and then I got in my drunken
High state of mind that night I went on
my phone in the middle of the night when
everyone left and I ordered your exact
outfit except I got in an extra small
because I messed up the size so now
Jasmine has it oh nice yeah yeah nice
you know Jasmine wears the shirt nice
fit yeah yeah it uh yeah so so it was it
really was um it really was awesome and
uh I mean I you know I like like you I
usually at a party I try to Irish exit
yes or I I like I've had enough I really
don't I don't drink a lot these days you
know and I don't know I I have not been
at a party like that with that Vibe
since I'm dude I gotta I gotta think
College days dude yes it was like
everybody was going nuts yeah but in the
best possible way and it's one laughing
dancing running around things are
happening everywhere people are like I
mean it was just chaos and it's
Tuesday's uh actually Monday uh 10 a.m
Eastern Time Christy cast podcast
um I I it was one of those things where
we had just put our house up for sale on
the Staten Island house yeah because and
we had said like we're not entertainers
that's what we said we're not
entertainers we don't need a house
it's a Billy Joel song okay the
Entertainer entertain us and we're not
entertainers and I said
and then we have that party well that
party begs the difference that's that's
what I'm saying you have that but that's
what like sometimes the universe
not in the co-op no you can't do it but
but I I think it's like one of those
things where like a decision you know
when you're making a decision they
always put like a little as Ryan
holiday's books say the obstacle is the
way they always they they put a little
obstacle up the universe they were like
do you really want to leave because you
can have all these types of parties and
all these types of fun yeah but at one
point someone cannonballed fully clothed
yeah and thought that person thought
that other people gonna jump in the pool
nobody did so it kind of sucks when she
was just swimming around dude your
friend is the worm is
may I had met him in the past but I
didn't I wasn't exposed to him in the
way that I was at your party that dude
is a living walking legend legend dude I
he was legendary to me from the one
night you've known him for what decades
decades and you had a lifetime of a
lifetime a lifetime I've sent you some
pictures from throughout the years yeah
send you some pictures it should be like
The Truman Show man I I would just watch
a 24-hour feed you know it's for his
life you know you're a good fun guy when
you're a wife and family leave without
you yeah they left the party they said
I'm not dealing with it you deal with
him and then supposedly he was offering
to give people blow jobs on the
Verrazano Bridge driving home
no he he um he was fun at the beginning
of the party even right he's just a cool
guy laid back fun vibe what have you but
then it just got everyone just got
progressively but everybody was getting
it at the same time so it was like a
parallel everybody was getting amped up
you know he's one of those guys where
you know he's not in you know
the entertainment world or anything like
that is a former cop actually
his former we'll watch this in a second
he's a former cop actually and he but he
just does like he just fits in like he
could be hanging out with Drake and he
would Drake would love him yeah man you
know he's not gonna ever ask for a
picture he's not that good he's making
me laugh man and then he just was
busting moves like left and right oh
dancing dancing right like singing
rapping it was just he was he was he was
like you hired entertainment yeah and
then he said he literally couldn't walk
the next day he's like what did I do to
my knees and I sent in the videos of him
dancing he was like I don't remember any
of that
the dance was had to be made up on the
spot oh yeah dude he improvs yeah yeah
because that was that was uh he looked
like an odd he looked like a like a that
was that was odd what's crazy about him
too is he's like when we were kids he's
like a sick graffiti artist he was the
guy that would like hang underneath the
Trestle and do graffiti that's wild
pretty cool right yeah yeah well shout
out Chris Shout out all right here we go
this Morgan I've seen this video before
what is this this there's a point I'm
okay if I watch the ball as long as no
one's really like hurt like I like one
one girl gets jumped to something I
don't want to see it do you know Morgan
Wallen songs yeah I don't uh maybe I
know them I don't know but I know only
quit in one thing at a time
uh was he the guy on SNL Jason you
you like a dancing hell no burning
through a town
burning going there chasing you
I don't know but if it's anything like
that it's wonderful somebody give me a
double shot
for daring or Nana now now I'm only
quitting one thing at a time do you did
you hear of uh
Dallas Dixon no or Dixon Dallas no
dude
We're not gonna be able to play it so I
don't know what song I don't know what
it is because but I could sing it to you
okay okay yes okay check this out I
I can't even I uh I I someone plays this
song for us like a month ago on the road
and we're like this can't be real burn
brings he goes my buddy brought this to
me he starts playing it and we're
listening like it sounds like a really
great song A Country Song and then it
gets graphically sexual uh like and and
but you don't expect it because it's a
really good song and actually the rest
of it is not graphically sexual but it
just go goes that way out of nowhere and
it was like it's your jaw drops and
immediately because it's a good song
it's in your head and we all learned it
and we started playing it the whole
weekend and then we were playing it as
the house music that weekend and then
burn came out because he was with us and
he came out played it to the crowd and
did 20 minutes on it and every time he
every time he hits you ever see the
Bernie Mac uh the famous Bernie yeah
where he's like hit them you know the
music yeah like hit a punchline and go
hit it and they would play The Line like
the rapidly sexual it was really really
funny I've come to learn the guy is a
very very uh talented musician that has
like four or five identities and he does
he does hip hop he does like like pop
music like rock music and then country
music so what can you can we google his
name what's his name pimpy his real name
is like
Dallas
um
Dixon down is Dixon Dallas gay good
looking singer responses sexuality
questions so he is he's not so the song
is is uh is is written in the voice of a
gay man God oh yeah because it just said
he's bouncing off my booty cheeks yeah
that's that's one of the best lines the
the uh the the chorus goes like this
he's bouncing off my booted cheeks I
love the way he rides I can hardly
breathe when he's pumping deep inside he
kisses on my neck and then I kiss him on
his call him daddy while I holler
man that boy so damn good looking
is that the intro song for hey baby
I kiss him on his head no but I had to
learn what that meant by the way
b-u-s-s-y your your boys
oh see yeah but I guess it's just
another version of the butt yeah doing a
box
okay but anyway but the song is I know
the whole song's from beginning to end I
was singing right now Bishop is a master
of the word just for friends listening
at home bushy is a mashup of the words
boy hey baby and hey baby you used to
refer to a mandanus while it's not clear
who the original Creator was the word
was coined primarily used by members of
the lgbtq plus community and has been in
a few since 1992 which is 30 years which
made me feel immediately out of touch
yeah like I didn't know this I don't
know slime yeah I don't know I thought I
knew all the lgbtq slang yeah but I'm
telling you dude when you leave tonight
you put that on your Spotify it it
because I'm not into contemporary
country no offense okay but it's it's
just something really has to break
through to get to me like I love Old
Country you like Old Country yeah let me
tell if you like old country Morgan
Wallen is a good pick also Luke Combs
okay Luke Combs these guys are they're
good okay country New Balance sneakers
are coming back yeah they are and you
are at the forefronto
um but I'm telling you the the song is
so it's such a good song you have no
idea like contemporary country and you
have no idea that lyrics about are
coming
you it doesn't start out that way zilch
zilch at all you have no idea it just
says pretty dope he says uh there's
something about the way you look in my
eyes
like a starry night you light up my sky
you're heading closer and my heart
starts to pound I hear you sigh you know
I love that sound he's bouncing off my
booty cheeks I love the way he rides I
can hardly breathe when he's bumping
deep inside it gives us a mom again then
I'll kill someone
Daddy when I holler man that boy's so
damn good looking images
um I know
we make love and when he kiss me I don't
want it to end every day we spend
together I grow more into him man I I
don't have the words to sing I don't
know any words to say so I wrote this
little note just to prove it so you know
I got some time if you got some time to
remember rhyme baby let me remind you
while I lay you down you got the kind of
love I've only seen in my dreams baby
you're my everything
so that just down the business because I
ain't wasting no time just you wait and
see
love it I forgot I forgot stuff out of
order and it's probably another verse
but but I I I learned it just so I could
call Steve and leave a voicemail and
sing the entire thing from beginning to
end without messing up yeah I was
driving down to Jersey I had like a 90
minute ride so I played it on a loop for
like 75 minutes and sang it every time
it's it's it's it's a hard song to learn
actually really and then after I got
it's a three minute song I got it
I left a voicemail uh I left a voice
text on Steve's thing I sang it from the
beginning to the end off the Dome
amazing yeah if it came on I would know
the words but yeah I I I I'm happy
always happy to find new music because I
am getting uh bored now of all the like
songs that I have on Spotify yeah I just
play the same song You Gotta use Spotify
to find new music you know you could do
that yeah but but I do but but like what
like like what do I put in baby
America's number one meal hellofresh
hellofresh we talk about it week after
week we love it if you want to look into
start your fresh fall routine hellofresh
has got you covered they do all the meal
planning shopping they deliver
everything you need to cook up a tasty
meal right at home they do the hard part
and you get to take the credit when it
comes to options honestly more is more
that's why hellofresh's menu includes 40
recipes and over 100 add-on items to
choose every single week a new season
calls for new meals and hellofresh has a
fresh fall lineup of delicious dinners
and more to choose from take your pick
from 40 weekly recipes that will suit
your lifestyle when you get Hella fresh
you know you're getting top-notch
produce it travels from the farm to your
door in less than seven days we love it
my family uses it and right now again we
talk about this week after week we don't
even know how this company makes money
because they give away so much of their
food for free go to hellofresh.com 50
hey babe and use the code five zero hey
babe for 50 off plus 15 off the next two
months how do they make a profit I do
not know but go to hellofresh.com five
zero hey babe and use code five zero hey
babe from five zero fifty percent off
plus 15 off for the next two months
hellofresh America America's number one
meal kit oh dude Viator I know you
should do the commercials literally why
am I not the spokesperson for Viator I
have been using this app the first time
I use viratory was like 2012. I've been
using this thing for 11 blowing up and
you've been there since you're a day one
I've been day one son yeah Viator what
is viador 300
000 bookable travel experiences in over
190 countries they offer everything from
simple tours to Extreme Adventures and
all the niche interesting stuff in
between Viator is the place to go to
book memorable travel when I land in a
city to do a show yeah when I'm
traveling my family it's all day but
when I land in the city do a show the
very first app I go on is Viator I click
the the you know the city I'm in and I
see all the tours that might be able to
fit into my day I've went on walking
tours history tours
um I've went on uh food tasting tours
yeah anything but cruises I go to them
before I go to the concierge how about
that yeah catch me outside how about
that catch me outside Viator it's
awesome it's a website and app where you
can book travel experiences like my
walking underground walking tour ghost
tour that I did in Edinburgh Scotland
they offer everything from simple tours
to Extreme Adventures as Sal said 300
000 bookable experiences in 190
countries and they have millions of real
traveler reviews that's the part I love
about it the most is you can kind of
weed through which tours are worth it
and which tours aren't because the
people give genuine feedback and I know
it's genuine feedback and not Bots
because they curse in the reviews
but the coolest thing is like the date
there's so many day trips that's like
where they really shine I thrive in the
day and the day I'm a daytime guy and
Viator is there for you download the
Viator app now and use the code viator10
that's
v-i-a-t-o-r-10 for 10 off your first
booking in the app one app over 300 000
travel experiences you'll remember do
more with Viator
well first of all you can do like if you
like certain things they suggest other
things and once you do their suggestions
enough it kind of like jumps genres
because ultimately you're going to get a
couple of songs that are kind of genre
bending and they use it to go elsewhere
so you really can surf and like find
that but you could also put on an artist
that you like they're like their kind of
playlist station or their radio like
Pandora does and then they'll show you
like extensions of that I feel like I do
that but I still you know how sometimes
like when you're just like in a mood and
it's probably like an anxiety and
indecisiveness you have too many options
like when you have like so many stations
on like a cable network like you can't
pick anything yeah that's what I think
happens to me with music where I'm like
I don't want to listen to any of these
songs
yep is that stupid no that happens a lot
you have to break out
breakdown
stop to I ask you that one don't break
it
[Music]
I want to say break again sister one hit
wonder ladies no earlier I don't know
yeah
that's a song that's a good song that's
a song right now if you're a kid and you
don't know The Pointer Sisters the very
young yeah uh they s they I mean that's
that's a Bop he's so shy yeah I love
that song love it here we go criminal
actually I'm criminal he's a hero conv
he got caught he cut off 37 man buns and
one day claims he was doing the Lord's
work and smiling his mug shot would you
ever do in a man bun
a man bun no it's not for me but you
don't disparage people who want to do it
I'll live your life I mean I I don't
think
I want to stump you with music please oh
it stumped you with Morgan Wallen yeah
you could sell me you could totally sell
me I don't really know I think you know
I think you know a lot about music in
movies and wrestling yeah but I don't
know the things you that I don't know I
don't know I don't know I wonder what I
know more about than you do because it's
a lot no no geography and history to
name one
yeah but that's big yeah but that's not
fun you know what I mean well it can be
and as a matter of fact as I get older
I'm starting to be like I want to do a
deep history dive again what do you want
to know ask me what do you want to know
what's it what's something that you're
thinking about in history I'll see if I
can answer it there's something else in
there sure how did the printing press uh
revolutionize the the the industrial era
Revolution yeah Benjamin Franklin he was
the one of the forefronts of the
printing press printing presses were big
back in colonial times and Benjamin
Franklin was one of the ones who made
that a massive business it's the
printing press how it it was around way
before the Industrial Revolution oh it
was it was what helped the Industrial
Revolution the automobile locomotives
yeah yeah that type of stuff Andrew Carn
steel into steel industry Big Industry
we are still some people think of the
industrial the byproduct of this we're
we're only leaving the Industrial
Revolution now to go the technology
computer Revolution
digital yeah some people think like the
Industrial Revolution like we were born
into it like it's it's like the thing is
with the Industrial Revolution is it
made things go like
you you know if you were born in the
1500s and then I took you out into
another dimension like the Mexican alien
and put you into the dimension in 1700s
we're heading there your life wasn't
that much different like people in the
1500s and 1700s they were advancements
of course but it wasn't radically
different where if I took you to
Revolution if I took you from 1940 and
then plucked you into 1980 just 40 years
your entire life you would have no idea
what's going on correct because of
technology and exponential it's now it's
exponential so you give us if you pluck
this out 30 years from now we're going
to be here God bless God bless
um so 30 years from now do you think
that this will be nearly unrecognizable
uh I do I think that with the
advancement I mean just look at
something this person's day-to-day
looking when you something that's filmed
in 2008 look at the footage of 911 that
was only 2001 it looks it looks like
footage the old school footage yeah oh
yeah you don't want it actually you
don't have to look at that yeah look at
the footage of something else maybe look
at from 2000 anything look at look at
2012 look at you know the NBA finals in
2012. you could tell watch early curb
early throw one of those on it looks
like someone literally did with that
camcorder yeah yeah it's so so I do
think that we're on the way to kind of
everything you know uh changing now
um and I think like yeah with AI I mean
I think AI is the that's the thing
that's the biggest change that we're
just gonna have to get we're not you
ready for this here's Chris here's
here's we're coming into Christian
conspiracies we're coming into we're
coming into Chrissy low blood sugar
we're coming into Chrissy just I need to
get this stuff out I think that what is
happening
what is happening is that our government
I don't know what side I have no idea
what side but I think there is a plan to
cause and allegedly allegedly I think
there is a PLA and by the way get your
uh
um allegedly get your allegedly if you
think you have an alleged lesbian or a
picture of her or if you are an alleged
lesbian if you're a lesbian then never
gets uh never gets uh asked if you are
like no one could really tell uh or like
if you are not and everyone thinks you
are or we have a friend that way or you
just saw a fun photo that might be up
for debate no pressure Network the thing
is Gmail you got to send the answer
though so we can understand but we will
start pulling them out and we're going
to start putting them on the show so we
want you we want to get your
questionable lesbians for that identify
yourself as straight or gay so we
understand we have a you know so so what
what I think is happening is they're
causing so much Anarchy and so much like
Lawless and it's going to be over the
course of 20 years that and the
defunding of the police and all that is
what they're going to do like Society is
going to beg for AI and robots to come
in and start policing us we're gonna
over we're gonna willingly give them the
keys because we're like humans can't do
it anymore already in China if like
China right now
like a busy street of bars like let's
call Downtown Shanghai we're having a
nice sign Donna chat you know we're just
two we're two Chinese guys hanging out
yeah two Chinese ho Yang these are our
names and and these are common names in
China and we're downtown in the bar
we're having fun we're eating egg drop
soup and we're drinking Chinese beers
and we're having we're doing Charles
though you want to be Charles yeah all
right I'll be um you could still be Mike
okay but we're having two in karaoke the
Chinese people love karaoke we're having
fun
if there's a bar fight or something like
that most likely the police are not
going to come with the police precinct
is going to do is send a drone nah an AI
drone it's going to start talking and
it's going to start digitally scanning
your face and digitally knowing where
everyone is and it'll tell you to stop
doing whatever and if you disobey those
commands they have you in a social
credit system they have your whereabouts
where you are you're all part of the
system and I think that that's probably
on the way here that's happening there
supposedly that's that's that's not
Freedom allegedly
wow that's wow that sounds like a sci-fi
movie it does but so I think that's
what's gonna happen is I almost think
all this stuff like because when you say
when we were talking about you know uh
oh how come uh how come
um uh you know um that people don't
serve prison time anymore and you can
commit and I think it's all on purpose
because they're like you know what we
want this to be like a little bit of
Anarchy so like you're going to want
this AI to come in that's that's that's
I know it sounds far-fetched yeah but
it's Theory well but you know what this
day and age not much this day and age
Girl Scout mom kicked out of Radio City
and barred from seeing the Rockettes
after facial recognition Tech identified
her so the facial recognition technology
is that's the thing that that's really
that's getting people because they have
everybody has our you know the iPhones
and all that they all have our face they
have a digital scan of us so yeah you
got to be careful you're saying that
Apple holds that and you know it's
supposed to be
ours right rirp but you're saying that
who knows one day
it's all there when you came to see my
show at Radio City hacked yo smile I
hope you smiled when you walked in they
had your face wow it's like they should
do it like at the end when you come out
of the show like a roller coaster if you
want to get your picture
it
dude this is I saw this Sudafed Benadryl
and most decongestants don't work yeah I
saw that and I was like wow this is yeah
that's crazy so do we get money back now
we should we should right or to go
further into your conspiracy a lot of
people are saying they want to stop
over-the-counter drugs so you need
medical coverage for every single little
thing interesting that makes sense that
makes sense yeah that's terrible too
yeah I think uh terrible twos my
daughter's in yeah um I think uh so oh
my God how did they get away with that
though
well it's not FDA no I think they did a
big test on it and they just found that
it doesn't work that well what they said
works one thing that was came out of
this test so that really works I think
it's D I think it's stomach stuff better
even as good as some like
anti-diarrhealas-ish turmeric if you
just take turmeric that works as good as
like Pepto really yeah that's came out
of this yeah so the FDA panel found that
vanilla friend
friend
FDA panel found in fentanyl the active
ingredient in Sudafed Benadryl Ben
elephant Vanellope yeah
correct
Sudafed Benadryl and Robitussin that
that literally useless that lean
nearly useless in other popular
decongestants useless at reducing nasal
congestion balls
the panel here we go The Advisory panels
ruling might lead to these oral products
being pulled off the shelves but nasal
sprays containing containing
phenylephrine are unaffected by the
ruling wow so if you you know that's one
thing that is good up your nose that's
so bad that like when people need you
the most because they can't breathe they
weren't even helping yeah they weren't
even helping and that's bad PR for them
that's that's not good they can't that's
gonna be they're going to go under right
I met a guy the other day who said to me
he's dead serious he said for 15 years
without missing one day because he can't
sleep for 15 years without missing one
day has either taken a Benadryl or a
NyQuil to fall asleep without missing
one day and I said your liver is going
to fail and he goes how
and I said your liver it's like you're
drinking alcohol every night he goes
it's not I was like that's bad that's
got to be real bad I was like you're
gonna go into liver you can't do that
your liver you have the liver of an
alcoholic right right he's taking what
you said 15 years 15 no he hasn't missed
one day six like that's like five
thousand six thousand pills
yeah right I wanted to see 65 times 10
is 36 600 yeah I have that very good on
top 46 5500 very good in math it was it
was all estimations I I I was I was well
like wow what's your take on vitamins
you think those are a waste you think
you PM right out we get all the
nutrition we need from anything that we
eat I think probably if you eat really
really healthy you'll get the vitamins
but none of us do that I certainly don't
do that so I like to take the vitamins I
would much rather just swallow the pill
and get it down but the athletic greens
what I've been doing is I've been taking
a scoop of athletic greens a scoop of
athlean X
um protein and then a scoop of naked
peanut butter powder
water and a little milk mixing that up
and it's actually a very good protein
shake that sounds great yeah that sounds
delicious yeah it is real the peanut
butter powder oh yeah I know about it I
had it with yogurt today I had yogurt
here's my breakfast today ready yogurt
Chobani Chobani yogurt fat you know the
whole like the good one with the red top
there's like 10 grams 12 grams of
protein plain but put it in the bowl put
a little bit of Honey at the bottom I
put the honey in first put a little bit
of honey in first just to drop raw raw
through from Staten Island because you
want the local honey that helps with
allergies okay wherever you live and you
want the local honey to help with
allergies if Benadryl ain't gonna do
nothing the bees are going to help us so
honey oh that's interesting yogurt
cinnamon
chia seeds naked peanut butter powder
sounds great walnuts banana
blueberries and you ready for this one
square of dark chocolate 85 cacao cacao
cacao bang mixed it all up bang There
You Go Cacao is one of the most fun
words to say is it not Chrissy cacao
cacao cacao cacao kale so what do you
think of that type of breakfast that
should have sent you through the day not
hungry I think well I ate about an hour
and a half vibrant protein in that yeah
I ate an hour and a half later okay
because I've been eating eggs too much
did you freestyle that yes this morning
you know what because you know what
Jasmine and I got into a fight right and
I wanted to show her that I I can I can
handle this with or without you honey I
can make myself my own breakfast
and then she said to me she goes are you
trying to prove to me and prove to
yourself you don't need me that you know
you want to fight you want to guess
you're like scooping powders yeah she
was like I know exactly what you were
doing she's like you're I can make this
better for you right you know exactly I
was like I literally I'll make my
breakfast every day I don't need you if
you want to act like that right so I was
just I said let me get every ingredient
in the cupboard and throw it in you're
like looking back
this is better than anyone I've ever had
garlic powder adobo
influence influencers American Airlines
meltdown um Instagram famous you effing
bomb that's why I fly Delta
quip have you heard of it dude I've
heard of it I use the show yeah me too
they sent me a box of it and they're not
you you don't have it I didn't get sent
a box here but I ordered my quip in a
box
uh I I I was given it as a gift a few
years ago yeah because we travel so much
and I use an electric toothbrush at home
yes but this is wild because the one I
use is bulky and then I got this one and
looks like a regular toothbrush and it
right and it's electric babe
I use it at home but then I throw it in
the bag now I got an electric toothbrush
on the road let me tell you some my
pearlies have never been windy dude your
teeth look so white I want to cancel
them yeah buy a tour it's a multi a
multi-use travel cover that doubles as a
mirror mount for Less clutter skip the
batteries and snap in it healthy habits
with the new rechargeable electric
toothbrush all the features the original
quip plus one magnetic charge Powers up
to three months of brushing mints and
gum also they have a water flosser now
it hits all the right spots with gentle
or deep clean pressure at the touch of a
button has an extra wide lid that fits
right under the faucet it fills up in
seconds seven dollar replacement floss
tips shipped to you every three months
to keep things flowing smoothly the
mincing gum did you touch on that to
equip electric toothbrushes loved by
over 9 million mouths
loves it yeah I absolutely love it all
right boys I love your mouth with quip
uh if you if you go to get quip that's
q-u-i-p get quick.com slash hey babe
right now you'll get 20 off any electric
toothbrush mint and gum dispenser or
water flosser that's your 20 off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com hey babe spelled
g-e-t-q-u-i-p.com slash hey babe quip
the good habits company oh yeah so
remember the other day when you and I
were just hanging out we started shaving
together with Harry's that was a great
day well real show connected half the
time I shave I shave for you you do
shave for me I do and you shave with me
yes yes because you don't like it when
it's when it's too rough no I don't like
it when it's too rough because when I
talk to you and I we have a serious
conversation I like the caress your
cheek just to note to let you know that
I'm focused how many times have you and
I been hanging out we're having fun we
got nothing to do we start shaving each
other we always turn to Harry too many
times Bud too many times it's always fun
no matter why you shave Harry's got you
covered for the best shave of your life
at a good price a price so great from
the legendary high quality raises they
have skin products exfoliating face wash
they have so much more than just razors
right they got the Hydrating Lotion they
have everything the starter set is a 13
value for just three dollars at
harrys.com hey babe it includes a five
blade German engineered razor weighted
handle foaming shave gel and a travel
cover scheduled delivery for refills as
low as two dollars half of what you pay
for other blades there's no reason not
to try it babes very high customer
satisfaction and they still offer that
no risk trial get your best shade
ever this song with Harry's raises and
skincare products get a 13 starter kit
set for just three dollars at harrys.com
hey babe that is Harry's
h-a-r-r-y-s.com slash hey babe for a
three dollar Starter Set let's see
Kim K everyone looks like Kimmy K now
um Instagram famous you've been bummed
you hey babe bum what's her name Morgan
Osman is she Instagram famous Fame
doesn't mean anything anymore can we
just be honest no it doesn't it doesn't
mean anything and also if you had to say
Instagram famous shame it's one of those
things where we're in a time now where
Fame
it does it it's it it's it just doesn't
mean anything it's been said lost its
lore it has like it's Frank Sinatra and
back fame still meant something like in
the 90s but it doesn't mean any is it
social media that ruined it what is or
is it reality TV it's a it's a I think
it's a pinch of both but I think social
media really did well I think people
used to be real humans before they got
famous
you know I mean they had real life
experience they were artists now it's
just kind of Race To famous mountains
well now you see the cool kids of the
world like the ones who are actually
let's call them like real famous like it
like an actor or something they post
less now it's about now it's about go
it's almost reverted right now it's
about I'm doing less but I'll get more
I'm going let I'm showing you less of
behind the scenes yeah I'm using this as
a promotional page you will see nothing
about my life and that's I've noticed
like the people are doing that are
getting more comments like you know like
it used to be the cool thing to do is
show me everything but now the cool kids
they have only one picture they're not
following anyone that's because if if I
let you kick me in the nuts I would be
famous the next day right like so it's
like why do you want to partake in that
I mean I mean there's so many this
famous I mean I I sometimes I'll I'll be
out on the road or something a mole is
shut down and I'm like what the hell
who's there and they say a name and I
have like I'm like you know it's not
like an okay Boomer situation I'm just
like okay finds Tick Tock and then you
go look and it's like this person they
just did the Cabbage Patch
you know they have the account six
months old they're shutting down the
mall for this person right it's the
blind leading the blind really yeah and
if you if you feel that you're offended
by that then maybe you're better than
that you know well if you feel your
offended by that you can go ahead and
take it up at Bloom Cafe take it up with
Bloom Cafe Bay Street yeah so I think
not saying that there's no talented
people out there on Tick Tock maybe
there is but I mean how many people are
famous every day and that's insane I'm
not even disparaging them if you are
famous from you know whatever you may be
doing your talent that lives on Tick
Tock an Instagram good for you I'm just
saying though from from for me like I
still would rather you have less but
like be actually really talented like a
singer you know a stand-up comic a
dancer but it's like you didn't if if
you're not viral going viral off that
you know who cares because I think
eventually the same way it came around
with celebrities now posting less real
actually talented people posting less
it'll come around too where eventually I
believe everybody running to do the new
trendy thing will will become hack and
whack and then you know the talent will
rise to the top again what decade would
you want to have your Peak 10 years of
your career in 90s baby 1999 for a
comedian 19. if we if Sal and I if Sal
and I maybe comedy aside okay but I just
want to say if comedy aside if Sal and I
had a show like this like if this was a
sick we'd both be worth 50 million
dollars plus no truly and they would
have given us in 1990 if the fans don't
know like the com you would have back in
the 90s
you would have been Sal and I would have
just been given a development Deal CBS
or somebody would have handed us three
million dollars each just take it just
for the hopes of me they were so much
money yeah but it's gone now that
doesn't exist anymore no not at all now
you have to do 10 things yeah and you
got to promote yourself constant big
thing constantly promoting yourself yeah
I would do if a comedy aside I'd
probably do 80s 80s comedy side 80s
what's the reason it's uh
no I would do I don't know 80 seems like
um just dope I mean like you know you
had like a lot of things like music and
art were like really like popping and
converging and stuff in the 80s what's
better than 80s music and yeah just the
80s Vibes all around man you know like I
don't know I just feel like don't even
feel like 70s and 60s were the only time
of original ideas and everything else is
just like adding a level to a house I I
would include the 80s in there though
kind of error was something uh I really
I mean really hip-hop was further
developed mostly in in the 80s you don't
you don't uh romanticize the 90s and
think about the 90s I do but if I had to
pick a year to be what was it look
famous in
Peak 10 years 80s oh if I could go like
if I could do like
85 to 95 that might be nice
I think up to 2016 was a good spot too
yeah yeah you think 20 I rewatched Broad
City and it's hilarious and like I'm
like what a nice pocket of Fame to have
before you could do comedy before crime
and woke culture you see woke culture
kind of starting then that all came with
when Trump got elected right yeah yeah
it feels like that was like the the
answer to that was kind of going too far
the other way but that is you know it's
already seven eight years ago now coming
up on it so it's like yeah and I've been
kicked in us on my show there you go
there you go yeah different context but
I mean you could turn on the camera kick
me in the nuts and it'll be a one second
video and I'll be famous or you can
write a whole thing around it and make
believe that you're on a talk show with
your wife who doesn't approve of things
that you do and then she kicks you in
the nuts to prove a point that's it
either way though either way you can
watch all those episodes and more on TBS
did I tell you the uh the first the the
two Vic shows sold out
oh there you go I told you as I knew
they would they sold yeah well they they
have the holes and kills for like the
cameras and stuff but they sold out and
so we just we we're adding another night
so big show what's the date it's well
the original show was December 2nd the
two shows and now we're adding two on
Friday December 1st okay so those
original shows were Saturday night yeah
by the time this era still have be on be
on sale already but I'm not adding any
more after that so if you didn't jump at
these right away and you want to still
get them get them on this one because
I'm not hitting any more after that get
them and thank you so much by the way
it's gonna be great calm gonna be a
great special we don't know where it's
going to Premiere yet the special not
yet not yet but I am taking one inside
info you do know or you really don't
know uh though just there's like I mean
you know it's like a couple places I'll
secretly record it please get that at
patreon.com it's all about the money
babe I told you what we're doing we're
gonna pick I'm shutting down I think I'm
shutting down my patreon I don't want to
do the patreon I mean I love the patreon
but I just it's just too much content
all the time I'd rather just do one show
with you one show with Christy chaos and
like less is more all right you know
unless you want to start a patreon
no uh one quick thing that I'm doing I
didn't tell you if I'm doing I don't
know if I told you this but I'm pulling
one person out of any of my tapings
Friday night included okay any of the
Four showings any seat doesn't matter
where you're sitting I'm gonna pull a
ticket and that person and plus one will
fly to New York put them in a hotel and
take them on the set of the show imagine
that person is from Staten Island and
then you got to get you get them like a
bus fare yeah I'm not gonna I'm just
gonna it's gonna be random so I don't
know what if they're like from Sydney
Australia that sucks to be me but you'll
do it it sucks to be me first class nah
oh not from Sydney not even from you
know you know Pittsburgh no no ticket
Chicago first class it's a plus one and
it's a plus one oh it's a plus one I
didn't realize yeah yeah but it's not
like food or anything right when did you
say all expenses pay what do you think
all expenses paid to me means flight and
hotel it doesn't mean food okay that's
what I'm doing okay yeah that's flying I
would understand flight and hotel I mean
if the tickets are reasonable maybe we
do a first-class situation right but I
didn't promise that okay
let's feel urged to check phones after
just 15 minutes of driving I feel it in
like 15 seconds yeah 15 minutes is a lot
and gen Z yeah I mean that's that's
insane well no but Genty but what's
interesting about you we're older than
that we want to check it sooner than
that but we're more addicted than these
kids these kids aren't as addicted to
their phones as you think I have to beg
to differ ones nope I'm telling you no
the cool thing is they don't text back
they're not on their phones as much
anymore the phones are like Boomer no I
think Am I Wrong is your sister on the
phone a lot she's a gen Zer you
constantly just don't answer you that's
all they just don't answer you but
they're on the phone doing other
but they don't want to take that take
that dose of medicine they see it the
second it drops but I kind of get that
it's a lot of energy to answer a text
sometimes I don't know bro are you
kidding me right now I have how many
texts you got right now you look at that
that's unanswered he has Sal has 195
unanswered texts and 96 missed calls I'm
kind of the same way what's the longest
you've ever went before you answer the
text what about emails oh six months
and then when you just respond six
months later yes yeah what I do is what
I do is I used to just like first there
was no pinning then they let you pin it
but then they won't let you pin nine so
you're pinning a text to the top to one
day answer to remember it but now I do a
different thing I didn't realize until
recently you could just go to unanswered
and look at all the unanswereds so I
don't have to scroll like seven months
so I just what I do is when I actually
have a moment to answer somebody I go to
filter to only unanswered I scroll all
the way to the last one and start with
the end so let's see how long that is
right now let's see how long has anyone
ever called you out on that no because I
just say I'm sorry I'm real busy I just
I can't keep up I can't keep up the last
one is is from
this ain't too bad actually August 25th
to 23 so that's not too bad not bad no
but what I think happened for sure for
sure is that they just started and
started deleting them because I had like
six month old ones but I don't know yeah
I'm like that with emails I have like 80
000 emails yeah I'm trying now to let
people know I literally just be like hey
dude just so you know like if I don't
answer you right away it's not me not
answering you I'll get to it eventually
I I think too like it's more like I've
never really had anyone or not recently
that I haven't answered that's been like
mad about it like it's really more on us
like I think most people don't get like
if I texted you and you didn't answer I
wouldn't well we know we understand you
know but not everyone does but it's it's
this is terrible oh my God 100 I have a
hundred I'm not 195 in the hole not
counting anything that's coming in now
yeah I mean think about like how life I
know there's a lot harder things in life
but it's like it's almost like back in
the day when you before this it was like
there was no way to reach me that must
have been peaceful yeah this is on this
is a monster they made out of this now
do you ever think about how like our
need as humans to always have some type
of problem to always have something
because right now we have literally
everything food is the basic needs are
met for almost every individual in
society even if you are homeless you can
get your basic needs met the government
of your respective country most likely
will help you but yet we still always
will find problems even billionaires
will have anxiety do you think it's
that's like a survival mechanism of
being a human because we had to overcome
problems to advance our society and
adapt I believe I'm pretty sure that it
is actually and I just watched I was
just talking about this with DeRosa I
watched that documentary on Netflix by
Jonah Hill Stutz oh yeah have you did
you watch it he touches on what does he
say he says he touches Jonah Hill no no
he touches yeah Jonah Hill touches on
the studs no no he touches on how that
we are we are literally wired and
programmed to be that way and instead we
should use it as like something that
pushes us forward instead of prohibits
us like look look I mean look you know
this might sound right but look at
everything as challenge that you have
like like something that is a built in
that you know that you have to overcome
like when it comes be excited change
your mindset to be excited to just have
to solve a problem to and grow and move
past that problem yeah so look at it as
like an opportunity every problem as an
opportunity yeah I think that there's
truth to that I think too also whatever
stress you're going under you're
creating it it's always you're you're
the one in charge no nobody else is
creating it you're creating if you
didn't you were like it and if you
didn't see it all I would recommend you
do it you see it I'm gonna watch it
again I don't want to I'm gonna watch
again take notes
that's where Larry David that's a curve
there no I'm not gonna do it yeah no I'm
not gonna yeah oh yeah you don't have to
but I will no you don't have to no
please
don't worry about it do you by the way
those messages it made me think of I
think I might have said this already but
Napoleon the emperor you know not get
off Napoleon knock it off for Napoleon
the top a lot Pizza okay
um
[Music]
Napoleon would if you would give him a
letter yeah say I'm The Courier Napoleon
yeah and I give you a letter you're
Napoleon yeah yeah Don't Kill the
Messenger right that's where it came
from no not that is
he he would say
you're in Napoleon
take the letter yeah you yeah and then
perfume and then you put the letter in
the desk put in your desk move French
Kiss mate
for three days you don't look at it you
don't look at it because what Napoleon
would say is anything of importance
after three days is probably not
important and if it still is important
then I will deal with it then if it's he
said I would always find I would always
find that after three days any problem
any problem that was so urgent at the
time in three day time 72 hour
has completely saw they said and nothing
is that urgent
new thing you went from Adam Sandler you
went from Billy Madison to to uh to the
Lioness Switzerland in the UFC Fighter's
name uh uh come on
and then you went to jock uh you went to
like the Pink Panther yeah you were all
over the map on that but but it was it
did sound like a billy Mega Billy
Madison but I landed the plane yeah you
landed the plane yeah not unlike this
F-35 is still missing still missing and
uh you know but isn't that crazy what
Napoleon used to do that yeah that is
Napoleon used to do that
no it did he said it really didn't yeah
he said it really didn't well think
about how long it took to get to him
true you know I think or matters of
urgency would not hand delivered yeah oh
wait they had to be yeah they were just
literally working they would just be
like yo open this now though bro like
open this now though bro and he's like
putting it that's like bro take it out
of the desk open it now I'm telling you
I don't know
they I mean literally wore back I'm
reading this book uh the British are
coming about like 1770 I thought it was
about uh sex in England yes okay that
too and and they were saying like
literally so much of the war like the
beginning stages of the war like we the
colonial continental army would lose
battles just because like the letter
would get delivered to the wrong guy
I would
hear and I deliver
to like you know General Pitcairn who's
supposed to be on like having a war like
in Lexington and yeah but he's really in
Concord or something like that and then
they give him this letter and they're
like these are the wrong coordinates
what are you talking about right and
then so that guy would just be standing
there like where's my Army and then the
British was like yeah I'm gonna kill you
now that's how the Franco person was
started that is how the Franco pressure
more started the James Franco pressure
more did you think I knew about the
Franco impression uh to be honest with
you I don't even think I know about the
Franco Prussian one good because I only
remember the name and I had no idea what
it is this has been hey babe
[Music]
hey babe